Millions worth of loot without your
knowledge have you ever noticed that
your computer has become slower but your
fan has started working overtime most
likely your computer has been subjected
to crypto jacking this is a cyber crime
in which miners use your computer to
mine cryptocurrencies whilst an average
PC with a built-in GPU is practically
useless for mining cryptocurrencies if
you send malware to thousands of
computers it will yield results the most
common way the code for crypto mining
could find its way onto your device is
if you clicked on a malicious link or
visited an unreliable site crypto
jacking doesn't harm your computer but
it does utilize the Computing capacity
of your PC consequently you pay the
electricity bill while the hacker makes
the profit how can you prevent crypto
jacking on your computer you can install
a special extension in your browser
sometimes crypto jacking scripts are
delivered via online advertising so
install an ad blocker and when working
on the internet disable JavaScript and
of course visit only trusted sites